hey what's up people of the internets
today we're going to talk about divorce
during the time of corona
romeo and juliet and titanic here we go
i was looking at some data this morning
and divorces
all across the world and especially in
the united states skyrocketing through
the roof
and make no mistake there's been
millions of people crammed in their
houses for months on end
trying to homeschool their kids trying
to graduate their kids
having work losing work working three
jobs just to keep your bills paid
scared to death we have a an election
coming
we've got a football season that's about
to be canceled we don't know what end is
up and people are getting stressed
people are stressed they have been
stressed
they're at the end of the rope is in
these moments of
deep stress deep tension that you find
out what you
and your relationships are made of and
if you find out your
relationships aren't as strong as you
thought they were or that you're not as
tough as you were
or you have been putting off
conversations you haven't had for years
you're frustrated you know like despite
all your rage you're still just a rat in
a cage
you're frustrated you're scared all of
it you really end up with
two options one you can just quit you
can fold up
you can sit in your swim trunks and eat
cheetos and have a frozen burrito for
the rest of your life
or two you can decide to do things
different and you can decide to say
i was made for more than this
and i want to do better i want my
relationships to be
better those are your two choices and
that's
it quit or stand up and say let's do
this let's change and grow so today i'm
talking about relationships when you
find yourself in the pit right in the
mud
and the stupidest most insidious myth
about relationships that i know it's so
frustrating
man it's nuts i wasted years of my life
believing this myth it woven its way
into my heart and i think it starts with
romeo and juliet
with titanic and all the other notebook
kind of movies
and books and literature and it's all
mythology that's woven its way into the
dna
of what we think relationships look like
and i'm the biggest romantic in the
world man i'm a total sap and so it
pains me to say this out loud
but i have to you deserve it and it's
true
there is no such thing as
cosmic star-crossed love there is no one
person
just for you roaming the earth going
through tough times waiting till y'all
turn the corners and see each other in
there it is
love is a decision i want to say that
again
love is a decision it's a choice it's a
thing you do
every day freaking romeo and juliet
listen
listen romeo and juliet were 14 year
olds
who saw each other at a party wanted to
hook up
secretly got married slept together and
then threw like a
murder-suicide temper tantrum that's
what we base
our our ideal of romance
and star-crossed love on or take titanic
a rich girl
meets a super good looking poor guy they
run around a boat for a while
he teaches her to spit like a man he
draws her nude they
hook up in the back of some old car and
then
she shoves him off of a floating door
and he drowns
and they love each other for eternity
and forever
and ever amen now i love the nobility of
it all way to go jack he hung in there
for rose
and because of him she got to drop
a bajillion dollar diamond into the
ocean whatever but in both cases
and in millions of books movies stories
across the the entire span of time sex
is substituted for intimacy
feelings are sometimes substituted for
reality
your feelings become the only important
thing
and what sucks is your feelings are
often not the most important thing
they play a critical role but sometimes
they lie to you
sometimes they deceive you sometimes
they're just signals
not destinations and this myth about
relationships if there's just one person
and maybe you made a mistake
maybe you aren't feeling it anymore
maybe it's just not
you know i just don't feel it between us
anymore that gets transposed from the
screen
and the page to the real world
to our normal lives where two people are
trying to work
raise kids get the yard done get laundry
done
replace the roof get out of debt
scratch and claw their way through life
and so what does this have to do with
spiking divorce rates
you are in a relationship and for the
last few months you've been struggling
things are hard your partner has gotten
more
frustrating more lazy more gross
you can't take any more wet towels or
scraping nacho cheese off the plates
if you see one more frozen burrito
wrapper
you're going to lose your mind and you
haven't been your best self
you've been whining more drinking more
netflixing more
and you guys had a political discussion
that you didn't know you probably should
have had four or five years ago now you
found
fissures and cracks in your relationship
that y'all didn't even know were there
or maybe the two of you are working
three jobs trying to keep food on the
table and the lights on
or maybe one of you has gone back to
work and gets to re-enter the world of
the living
while the other one's trying to work
from home and both simultaneously
homeschool two kids and not murder two
kids right
whatever your situation it doesn't feel
good anymore
it doesn't feel happy anymore it doesn't
feel
whole anymore and i get it it's so easy
to believe
it's so easy to think it's so easy to
feel
that if you just ended your relationship
things would feel better
right because right now ending your
relationship feels like
the one thing you can control in a world
that is spinning
madly out of control it feels like it
would feel so
good to be free to be untethered
to just not see their face
but i want to challenge you i want to
challenge you
because you can't tell me that doesn't
feel right if you're spending all your
time
not exercising not eating right not
taking care of your mental health
you can't tell me that you don't feel it
anymore that you've grown apart
when you've decided to stop trying to
co-create a future together
it may look really different than the
future you had envisioned or the future
that you didn't even talk about one
another because you just assumed each
other knew where the other one was going
so before you cut off the relationship
before you get divorced before you start
googling how do i
end this long-term relationship before
you quit i got a challenge for you and i
hope you will own it
and you will live into it even if for a
short time
just give it a shot but before i issue
the challenge
i want to be very clear if you are in an
abusive or
unsafe relationship if you are
with somebody who is an active addict
and they have no interest in sobriety
or if you are with somebody who is
committed to infidelity
they keep cheating on you and they have
no interest in stopping
any one of those three things this
challenge doesn't apply to you you need
to get with a counselor
a friend or mentor or an attorney and
start planning out your future
and the safety of you and your loved
ones okay but if that's not you
here's the challenge if you are
struggling
bickering complaining frustrated
if the word divorce has come into your
head if you've googled it after your
wife or husband's gone to bed
or if you and your wife and husband have
talked about it at the table like
maybe this isn't right maybe six years
in five years in
20 years in we just need to cut our
losses and move on
i want you to double down
i want to challenge you to double down
on your marriage on your relationships
on yourself take 30 days 60 days
61 days get a number in your heart
sit with your partner and let's go do
this i want you to decide
to do the things to fall back in love
with each other
because remember love is a decision love
is a choice
or it may be that you have to decide
that we're going to fall in love
together for the first time
maybe we got married for the wrong
reasons maybe we've got two kids and a
third on the way
maybe we've got three little kids under
six and our relationship is totally
different than it used to be
or maybe our kids are about to leave
home and i'm looking across the bedroom
i don't know who you are anymore
i want you to decide i'm gonna fall in
love again
i want you to decide i'm gonna fall in
love for the first time
we're gonna decide to get deeper and
stronger together
because this isn't romeo and juliet and
this is not titanic this is not a myth
this is the real world and i don't care
if you've been married for 18 months
for six years for 12 years for 20 years
for 40 years every marriage goes
up and down everybody in every marriage
has seasons where they look in the
mirror and think
what did i do is this the law i've been
cast
is this the rest of my life i wonder if
being with somebody else would be better
being alone would be better every
marriage has those moments every person
in every marriage has those moments
so i'm daring you to reimagine recommit
and restrengthen your relationship
your own heart and your future together
i want you to do these things ready here
we go number one
decide that he or she is
it they're it and etch
their name in stone number two
ask yourself if you have been worth a
crap being married to
what are you contributing to this
relationship are you getting sleep
are you eating right are you exercising
are you taking care of your mental
health
are you avoiding conversations you
should have had
are you connected to other people all
over the place and leaving your spouse
all alone either spiritually emotionally
intellectually
or physically what do you need to do to
get
yourself back on track number three
i love what emily nagatsky says here
which is define the offs and define the
ons
and spend your days turning off the offs
and on the awns love romance
intimacy they happen in a context these
decisions that we make
are made in a context so sit down for
the
hundredth time or some of you for the
first time
and ask your partner what are the things
that shut you
off what are the things that turn you
on and not just sexually not just but
what are the things that make
you fully on and everyone's got
different ecosystems right
it could be dishes clean house no
laundry
no debt safety going for walks together
regular intimacy
the kids already showered and in bed
text messages throughout the day little
notes reading a book together
going to church together i don't know
what it is everyone is different
but you need to find out your offsinons
and his or her offsinons and make it
your life's
mission to keep the ons on
and turn the offs off number four
do a weekly and daily check-in
what is your picture for today what does
your week
look like what can i do to make your day
your week better
and if you both live to turn the offs
off and the ons on and you both
live to paint pictures for each other
you will co-create a future
that your grandkids will talk about that
your grandparents never could have
imagined
in their lineage it's a choice it's a
decision
and number five start dating again and i
know we're all shut down and i know
we're all broke
have a date in the garage have a date
upstairs
have a date in your bedroom drag a table
in the backyard and have a quiet dinner
together
go for a walk i don't care what it is
but begin
courting each other again start dating
again
begin falling in love again
choose to fall in love again so that's
the 60-day
90-day 30-day challenge i don't care how
long you want to give yourself
but i'm asking you to go home tell your
husband
tell your wife you want to watch this
video together you want to recommit
together
today that we're not going out like this
we're not letting corona take us out
we're not letting the last six months
where our relationship frayed and begin
to untether
we're not letting it end like this
forever
and i know he screwed up a lot and i
know she was talking to him
and i know he was watching i know all of
that
and back in it doesn't mean we're not
going to go see a marriage counselor
and back in it doesn't mean we're going
to have years of trust building back
together
but back together means it is in stone i
love you
and you love me and we're in this
together
romeo juliet jack
they all died at the end of the movie
and they were way too young
you deserve more you're worth it and so
is your partner
i believe in you this is dr john delony
hit all the buttons subscribe send this
to your friends your grandparents your
pets
and follow me on the socials at john
delony and i'll talk to you soon
take care